l avant première vous le savez dans la
dinde avec y aller on avait andreas qui
était regard d'un génial crédit soir on
était au grand rex pour l'avant-première
d' allah d'un bon gentil qui aiment
pincho 6 mt vous à ce type et ap et
comme à tout avant première
internationale sur le tapis rouge il y
avait une ambiance de fou
[Musique]
pourtant l'animateur a tout fait pour le
chauffer le public mais c'était mal
parti
heureusement parmi les fans y avait un
humoriste
je crois que ça va n'a pas eu l'effet
escompté
quand j'ai pu parler aux fans je leur ai
demandé pourquoi il était venu et il
était clairement tout cela pour will
smith
oui mais c'est surtout la bombe 6%
peuple et je leur ai donc demandé quel
message qu'ils allaient adresser à will
smith et c'est là que c'est devenu
compliqué la vie au racing c'est cool
qui se laisse couler une photo d'elle et
après des heures à attendre sur l'appui
il a fini par arriver mais la maison
un message des fans ça a donné ça
du jasmin et arrivés et le message pour
elle c'était plutôt ça écrire tu as vu
comment les fraîches vas-y je vais taper
sans moule haut
enfin j'ai pu parler à will smith merci
beaucoup ne parlent pas français mais
pour nous il a fait un petit effort vous
salut les p'tits potins
[Applaudissements]
il est très sympa oui j'adore j'adore
motion rappelle je connais c'est son
frère aux normes et chaque mois je suis
j'ai toujours été fan de will smith pour
moi sommes ccc ccc la tasse et il sait
tout faire et l'excellence ou voulait-il
toner oui mais pas ce que je voulais
dire que c'est un bonheur les souvenirs
avec ses passes il que de la ténine si
on réagit pas surtout non amazonie c'est
pas une nouvelle machine à laver oui moi
je connais quelques personnes quelque
sept matches et merveilles marché pas
mais maintenant ça va mieux ici c'était
pipé ça doit les militants avaient une
âme est juste très fait qu ici énorme
ici qu'en ligue des champions là oh oui
oui si tu es ce que c'est ici c'est un
million et demi de téléspectateurs ici
offensive oui donc c'est pas parce que
tu mets un peignoir au barreau et tu
viens dire
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu veux dire est ce que je
peux dire que les américains c'est un
plaisir parce que quand ils viennent en
france ils font la promo ils jouent le
jeu de la promo interrompu son concert
avec m